>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAMPAIGNING IN KEY SENATE BATTLE
GROUND STATES, HE'S FINISHING UP
A RALLY RIGHT NOW, IN WEST
VIRGINIA, BEFORE HEADING TO
YAUNL LATER TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT GOING AFTER
DEMOCRATS HARD AHEAD OF THE
HIGH-STAKES MID TERMS FOUR DAYS
AWAY.
>> President Trump: THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO RAISE YOUR
TAXES, RESTORE JOB-KILLING
REGULATIONS, SHUT DOWN YOUR COAL
MINES.
THEY WILL SHUT THEM DOWN.
THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY YOUR GOOD
HEALTHCARE.
AND ESSENTIALLY, USE SOCIALISM
TO TURN AMERICA INTO VENEZUELA.
>> Dana: TRUMP TOUTING THE
BOOMING ECONOMY AFTER FINDING
OUT TODAY 250,000 JOBS WERE
ADDED IN OCTOBER.
>> President Trump: AMERICA NOW
HAS THE BEST ECONOMY, IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY, AND WE
WANT TO KEEP IT THAT WAY.
WE'VE CREATED 4.5 MILLION NEW
JOBS SINCE THE ELECTION.
A NUMBER THAT WAS UNTHINKABLE,
IF I WOULD HAVE SAID THAT DURING
THE CAMPAIGN, OH, THEY WOULD
HAVE GIVEN ME A HARD TIME.
THEY WOULD HAVE SAID PINOCCHIO,
THEY DO THE WHOLE THING.
SDP THE PRESIDENT HITTING ON A
CENTRAL THEME,st MIGRANT CARAVAN
THAT'S HEADED TOWARD THE UNITED
STATES.
>> President Trump: DEMOCRATS
WANT TO DON'TLY OPEN THE
BORDERS.
THEY HAVE THE CARAVAN, LET 'EM
IN, YOU WANT TO LET 'EM IN, DOES
ANYBODY WANT TO LET 'EM IN?
>> NO!
>> President Trump: CARAVAN
AFTER CARAVAN IS FORMING,
UNVETTED ILLEGAL ALIENS, TRYING
TO FLOOD INTO OUR COUNTRY, ON
YOUR DOLLAR, OVERWHELMING YOUR
SCHOOLS, DEPLETING YOUR
RESOURCES, AND ENDANGERING YOUR
COMMUNITY.
>> Dana: THERE WE GO.
THERE WAS ANOTHER FORMER --
FORMER PRESIDENT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL TODAY, LET'S PLAY THAT
FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA, THEN TAKE
IT AROUND THE TABLE.
>> WHILE YOU'RE DISTRACTED WITH
ALL OF THIS STUFF THEY'RE MAKING
UP, THEY ALSO ARE ROBBING YOU
BLIND.
I MEAN LOOK, LOOK, LOOK, OVER
THERE.
THEN THEY GIVE TAX CUTS TO
BILLIONAIRES.
LOOK, OVER THERE.
THEN THEY'RE LETTING POLLUTERS
POISON YOUR AIR AND WATER.
THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY TAKE
HEALTHCARE AWAY FROM MILLIONS OF
THE FIRST CHANCE THEY GET WHILE
YOU ARE DISTRACTED.
WITH STUFF THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> Dana: JESSE, LET ME HAND IT
OVER TO YOU.
BOTH FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVING FUN ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT OBAMA
LOOKING SPRY THERE, A LITTLE PEP
IN HIS STEP.
HE'S REALLY LOWERED HIMSELF, TO
A PLACE WHERE HE SHOULDN'T BE.
SOME ONE THAT'S JUST LEFT
OFFICE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN A
PRESIDENT THIS EARLY IN THE
CAMPAIGN SO PARTISANLY AGAINST
HIS SUCCESSOR IN THAT WAY.
BUT HE'S TRYING TO SALVAGE HIS
LEGACY.
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP HAS DON'TLY
DESTROYED IT.
THE PRESIDENT GOT GREAT NEWS
TODAY ON THE ECONOMY, A QUARTER
MILLION JOBS CREATED IN OCTOBER
DESPITE THE HURRICANE.
AND WITH OTHER BRIGHT SPOTS,
3.1% WAGE GROWTH, THE BEST WAGE
GROWTH FOR AMERICAN WORKERS IN A
DECADE.
ALSO, NEARLY 70,000 JOBS CREATED
IN CONSTRUCTION, AND MINING, AND
MANUFACTURING.
REMEMBER, THOSE JOBS WERE NEVER
COMING BACK, ACCORDING TO BARACK
OBAMA.
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT LEVEL SINCE
1969.
MOST AMERICANS WITH THE JOB IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND THE XWLEED HAS REALLY
DOWNPLAYED THIS ECONOMY.
THE MEDIA.
WHEN THERE WAS A 3.5% GDP
NUMBER, THE NIGHTLY NEWSCASTS,
THEY NEVER EVEN COVERED IT.
AND THEN TODAY, AXIOS SAID,
WELL, THE ECONOMY IS SHRINKING.
IT WENT FROM 4.2 TO 3.5, AND
THEY SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, A
RECESSION MAY BE AROUND THE
CORNER.
I DO THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
CLOSING STRONG ON THE MESSAGE OF
THE ECONOMY.
AND ON IMMIGRATION.
AND THIS BLUE WAVE THAT
EVERYBODY SAYS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, I'M NOT QUITE SO SURE
ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: MAYBE A LITTLE RIPPLE.
>> Jesse: MAYBE.
>> Dana: THE OTHER ECONOMIC
NUMBER, GREG, WAS THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RAPT FOR VETERANS
THAT THEY HAVE HAD IN A LONG
TIME.
>> Greg: THE ECONOMY ECONOMY IS
HOTTER THAN JESSE IN CUTOFFS.
[LAUGHING]
I HAVE A CAMERA IN YOUR DRESSING
ROOM.
HERE'S THE DEAL, THE MEDIA ISN'T
COVERING THIS NEWS, BECAUSE IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN BLAME
ON TRUMP.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO GIVE
CREDIT FOR.
THEY'D RATHER JUST DO THEIR
USUAL ANTI-TRUMP BLATHER, WHICH
ALSO HAPPENS TO JUNE UP THEIR
REVENUES QUITE WELL AS JEFF
ZUCKER HAS ADMITTED RECENTLY.
THE WAY I LOOK AT THE MID TERMS,
I PRAY THEY'RE OVER SOON, THE
REPUBLICANS WIN AND THE
DEMOCRATS LOSE.
NO MATTER WHAT.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE POLITICS ISN'T PERSONAL,
TO REPUBLICANS.
SO, IF YOU DO WELL, GREAT.
BUT I'M GOING TO HAVE DINNER.
IF YOU LOSE THE HOUSE, WELL,
THAT SUCKS.
BUT I'M GOING TO GO HAVE DINNER.
THE DEMOCRATS, SAY THEY WIN BIG,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
BECAUSE HE'S STILL GOING TO BE
IN CHARGE.
THAT EVIL TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
THERE.
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE ANGRY.
IF THEY LOSE WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THEY LOST BEFORE,
RIGHT?
IT WAS COUNTRYWIDE TANTRUM.
>> Dana: WE SHOULD HAVE HAD THE
SCREAM.
>> Greg: IT'S INTENSELY PERSONAL
FOR DEMOCRATS, PRIMARILY
LIBERALS WITH POLITICS, I DON'T
THINK THEY'RE EVER GOING TO BE
PLEASED BY THE OUTCOME.
WHERE THE REPUBLICANS, POLITICS
IS JUST A FACET IN YOUR LIFE,
JUST ONE PART OF IT.
IT'S NOT YOUR LIFE.
YOU KNOW, YOU LOSE THE HOUSE,
WELL, THAT'S LIFE.
I'M GOING TO PLAY WITH MY KIDS.
I DON'T HAVE KIDS.
>> Dana: JUAN, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO SAY.
>> Juan: I'M AMAZED, THE BEST
ECONOMY EVER, SAYS TRUMP, JESSE
BACKS THAT UP.
NOT TRUE.
YOU SAY IT'S NOT TRUE, WHY ARE
YOU PICKING ON THE PRESIDENT.
BUT IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
AND THE WHOLE IDEA OF THIS
INVADING ARMY IS COMING OKAY, MY
GOSH, YOU WANT TO LET 'EM IN.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST RIDICULOUS.
BUT TO ME, IT'S A POINT WHERE IN
THIS CAMPAIGN YOU LOOK AT WHERE
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING, WHAT HE
THINKS.
ED TODAY, WEST VIRGINIA, ALSO
INDIANA.
HE'S GOING INTO RED STATES.
I DON'T THINK HE WILL HAVE
SUCCESS STOPPING JOE MANCHIN
GETTING RE-ELECTED.
WHEN IT COMES TO JOE DONNELY,
THE DEMOCRAT IN THE RED STATE,
HE MAY HAVE SUCCESS, HE CAN STIR
UP THE BASE.
THAT'S ALL HE'S DOING.
THE WHOLE ATTACK ON THE CARAVAN,
EVERYTHING THAT HE SAYS ABOUT
THE CARAVAN BEING FILLED WITH
DISEASE, IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW, AT
SOME POINT YOU WANT TO THINK,
ABOUT THESE REPUBLICANS PAYING
ATTENTION?
>> Jesse: DIDN'T OBAMA SAY WE
WERE POISONING THE AIR AND
WATER?
[LAUGHING]
>> Juan: IT'S TRUE, TRUE.
>> Dana: MORGAN, YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT, WE HAVE -- GOING INTO A
WEEKEND, IT'S ALSO WHEN YOU HAVE
TO TURN BACK THE CLOCKS.
.
>> IT IS?
>> Dana: YEAH.
APPARENTLY, I THINK THAT'S GOOD
NEWS FOR REPUBLICANS, RIGHT?
I'M JUST KIDDING, NO IDEA.
TRENDS TELL US IN THE PAST.
>> I THINK IT ALL COMES DOWN TO
UNDECIDED VOTERS, WHICH ARE
LARGELY INDEPENDENT INTERESTS,
LARGELY MODERATES.
SOMETHING I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING, AND IN THIS BEFORE
THE MAIL BOMBER HAPPENED, BEFORE
THE TEMPLE SHOOTING HAPPENED,
MOST OF THOSE INDEPENDENT VOTERS
ARE REGISTERING, SAYING THEY
FELT UNSURE OF PUTTING THE
DEMOCRATS BACK IN POWER, THE
MESSAGE WORKS, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE TOO EXTREME.
THE EVENTS STOPPED THE MOMENTUM
THAT THEY HAD.
BUT THEY SORT OF SEEM LIKE, WILL
I VOTE, WILL I NOT VOTE.
IN ALL OF THE ELECTIONS IT
DEPENDS ON WHO CAN MOTIVATE
PEOPLE TO TURN OUT.
WHAT I'M FASCINATED BY, I
STARTED GOING THROUGH, YOU KNOW,
STATEMENT BY STATE, LOOKING AT
THE POLLING.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG
ELECTION NIGHT, I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WATCHING YOU, DANA.
>> Dana: JUAN TOO.
>> Greg: I WON'T.
>> YOU CAN COME TO MY PARTY.
>> Greg: GREAT.
>> AS THE WIND BLOWS, THE PACES,
THEY'RE A POINT APART, TWO
POINTS APART, WITHIN THE MARGIN
OF ERROR.
WE CAN SEE, THEN LOOKING EXACTLY
LIKE IT IS, WE CAN SEE THE HOUSE
LOOKING SIMILARLY OR WE CAN SEE,
WE CAN SEE SOMETHING GO STRAIGHT
UP OR DOWN FOR EITHER PARTY.
IT'S GOING TO BE A FASCINATING
EVENING.
ONE THING I WOULD SAY, IS TO PAY
ATTENTION NOT JUST TO THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE BUT THESE
GOVERNOR'S RACES.
12 OUT OF 13 REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS THAT ARE RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION ARE AHEAD.
BUT ABOUT 7 TO 9 OF THEM RUNNING
IN OPEN SEATS, IT'S NECK AND
NECK.
TALK ABOUT GEORGIA, FLORIDA.
THESE ARE THE RACES WHERE IT
COULD GO INTO RUNOFFS.
WE COULD BE UP ALL NIGHT.
>> Jesse: SOMETHING THAT MORGAN
SAID, THERE ARE A LOT OF HOUSE
RACES THAT A LOT OF
PROGNOSTICATORS THINK DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO GET THEM ALL.
THEY'RE WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT THIS
BLUE WAVE IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOU CAN SEE THE SITUATION,
DEMOCRATS PICK UP 20 SEATS IN
THE HOUSE.
AND COME UP A FEW SEATS SHORT.
THERE'S NO MASSIVE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY REGISTRATION GOING ON.
THERE'S NO MASSIVE ENTHUSIASM
GAP GOING ON.
THERE'S NO RECESSION GOING ON.
THERE'S JUST NOT A LOT OF
INDICATORS, LOOK AT THE GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL BAT LOT, WITHIN
SINGLE DIGITS.
THE DEMOCRATS DOWN IN THE
CONNECTICUT GOVERNOR'S RACE.
>> Dana: GOOD REASON.
>> Jesse: THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS YOU SCRATCH YOUR HEAD,
THE MEDIA WAS SO WRONG IN 2016,
COULD THIS BE A FLASHBACK OF
LAST TIME, A SILENT MAJORITY
THAT AREN'T TALKING TO POLLSTERS
THAT, COME OUT AND REALLY SHOCK
THE COUNTRY.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU LOOK AT THE
ADS, IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
AND THE ADS, BOTH ON THE
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
SIDE -- DVP WE HAVE A CHART.
>> Jesse: DANA LOVES HER CHARTS.
>> Dana: I SENT IT TO EVERYONE
IN THE MORNING.
>> Greg: 7:00 IN THE MORNING,
GREAT WHAT I WANT TO LOOK AT, 8
CHARTS FROM DANA.
SEND ME PICTURES OF YOUR DOG!
>> Dana: THAT CAN BE ARRANGED,
OF COURSE.
BUT THIS CHART, IF YOU GO TO
BLOOMBERG, IT TELLS YOU WHAT ADS
ARE RUNNING IN WHICH REJOJS OF
THE COUNTRY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY GOOD.
DIDN'T YOU THINK IT WAS
INTERESTING?
>> Jesse: I DIDN'T LOOK AT IT
EITHER.
[LAUGHING]
I OPENED IT THEN CLOSED IT.
>> Greg: WHO SENDS CHARTS BEFORE
9:00A.M.?
>> Dana: SOMEBODY HAS TO GET UP
EARLY TO WORK ON THE 2:00.
I WAS 10:30!
>> Juan: DANA, I VALUED IT,
APPRECIATED IT.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Juan: THE POINT I WAS GOING
TO MAKE BASED ON THE CHART, THAT
HEALTHCARE DOMINATES ON BOTH
SIDES, NOT THIS IMMIGRATIONS
DRIVEL, AND DEMOCRATS WANT OPEN
BORDERS.
AGAIN, IT'S LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS, ARE THEY SUCKERS?
>> Greg: SHOW THE CHART ONE MORE
TIME.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT -- THEY'RE
NOT SHOWING IT.
>> Dana: WE'LL SHOW THE CHART,
CAN YOU PULL IT UP?
>> Greg: IT'S NOT WORTH IT,
FORGET IT I WAS GOING TO SAY
IT'S A GREAT PLACEMAT FOR A